hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that was played today
unleashes in a sort of a mini match
between magnus carlsen
and uh 22 year old dutch international
master thomas
beerzen uh also could be pronounced
bertson
not really i'm never sure how to
pronounce those dutch uh dutch names but
let's go with bertson as
beerson sounds like uh sounds uh more
like berkeley's
if you've seen that show uh but yeah it
comes as a suggestion from uh samuel
sirique
on twitter who is a software engineer so
thank you for suggesting such a wild
game
uh it's been a while since we've had uh
such a nice one so without further ado
let's check it out so magnus opens with
the white piece he goes
c4 we have the english on the board we
have g6
uh going for the modern defense d4 uh we
have
c5 uh and now knight to f3 uh bersen
trades in the center we have captures
and captures and now bishop to g7
we have e for by magnus and now queen to
b6 with a double attack on the knight
here and magnus retreats it
knight back to b3 and now a5 going after
that
uh going after that knight on b3
preparing a4 and now uh there have been
games that reach this exact same
position where knight the c3 was played
also c5 is a known move here
but the move magnus plays is a new one
so already as of move seven we have a
completely new game
uh so the queen is under attack queen
moves to b4 this comes with
check and magnus blocks it bishop back
to d2 and now queen back to b6
saying that okay do you want to repeat
or what's happening here
but magnus shifts it over to c3 to
counter black's very strong bishop and
g7
of course black has no interest in
trading dark square bishop so knight to
f6
uh and now c5 pushing the queen further
back now you could go
for example to c7 you could go to c6
bertson decides to go
queen to e6 and now there's a double
attack on the e4 pawn
and magnus doesn't like defending it
with f3 could weaken the position a
little bit so instead he decides to
sacrifice the pawn he goes
uh into further developing his pieces
knight one to d2
and now knight captures on e4 uh we have
bishop captures on g7 and this is the uh
the the part when where the fun starts
because here
uh bersen is uh threatening to just move
the knight anywhere
and it will be checked to the white king
and okay obviously we're gonna move it
somewhere to be able to
grab the white queen but magnus just uh
plays bishop captures on g7
and he allows this uh his queen to be
captured so
this is what happens knight's the c3 a
nice discovery from the black queen
also you cannot block with the queen the
knight also covers that square
so bishop to e2 and now knight captures
on d1
uh bishop captures an h8 by magnus and
now
uh the knight has no squares where you
can go the knight will be captured even
the b2 square is still covered by the
bishop
so here uh not wanting to give up the
knight for nothing uh there's some place
knight captures uh on f2 king captures
and now
f6 trapping uh carlsen's bishop here
but magnus just goes rook h to e1 uh
now if the bishop moves the queen will
be under attack so queen moves all the
all the way back to g8 and now uh here
comes
bishop captures on f6 and this is the
the beauty
uh problem is that black should have
gone for something like king to d8 but
it would be silly to even mention such
things uh
as this is a bullet game so queen to g8
and
now comes bishop captures on f6 making
it impossible for black to capture the
bishop because
the queen on g8 is lost again so instead
after b
bishop captures an f6 we have queen to
f7 now pinning the bishop the bishop
cannot move the king is still on f2
and now comes knight to e4 again trying
to trigger black if you now capture with
the pawn then just knight v6 check picks
up the queen
so instead after knight to e4 we have
king to f8
and this is again a problem the king
belongs on d8 but again it's a bullet
game who could foresee such
things so king to f8 was played and now
magnus goes back
king to g1 now the bishop can move and
also uh the rook is coming to f1
so e captures on f6 and now uh it seems
like you could capture on f6
with the idea that if queen captures
rook to f1 will win the queen
but black can completely ignore this
just d5 and if you go rook f1 just
bishop f5 and uh
black is perfectly fine so instead after
this e captures on f6 we have knight to
d6
and this is why the king belonged on d8
because now
both the queen and the bishop and c8 are
under attack so
there's no way to defend the bishop here
you you just have to move the queen
somewhere
so the queen could come to e7 maybe you
could do something with queen to e3
check but
uh in the game queen to d5 was played
but now comes
bishop to c4 again attacking the queen
and now there simply is no good move for
black here
queen to h5 was played but now it's
actually a forced checkmate in three so
feel free to pause the video and to win
the game in three move stops
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
mating sequence and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
rook to e8 with check king to g7
rook to g8 with check king to h6 and now
of course
knight to f7 and this is now checkmate
as the knight covers both of these
squares and the rook prevents the king
from
going back to g7 this was not played in
the game however in the game uh after
queen to h5 magnus did go rook to e8 to
check king to g7 but now he didn't uh
see the mate in two immediately he uh
continued the king hunt uh so
rook the e7 check king to h6 and now
now knight to f7 is not checkmate
because the king can go back
so instead bishop the g8 here magnus is
preparing to capture with the rook
so uh queen back to g4 so you don't have
to give up the queen after rook captures
on h7
rook captures on h7 and now king to g5
with h4 with check magnus uh invites the
black king
deeper into the position came to f4 and
now rook to f1 with
check we have king to e3 and now rook to
e7
again with check uh we have king back to
d3 and now
bishop to c4 with check the knight
nicely guards the bishop from d6
king back to c2 and now rook to f2 with
check king to d1 and now interestingly
rook to e1
rook to e2 is checkmate in one move but
magnus decides to give up
one more rook before checkmating the
black king uh just
for good measure i imagine so rook the
e1 check was played
forcing the black king to capture king
captures and now of course
rook to f1 is checkmate as the knight
covers the d2 square
and interestingly uh
neither of the players made any big
mistakes in this game even though it's a
bullet game and it's a really crazy
bullet game both of them played a
really really great game it was uh
basically
uh it all came down to that uh one move
uh
let me just rewind okay there there
could have uh
they could have played some better moves
but for example here uh going to d8 uh
and the the position is perfectly fine
for black and even not allowing this
capture by the bishop just going back
to d8 right away instead of this queen
to g8 move and the black plays on but
uh those were basically the only uh
if you even want to call them mistakes
that that were made in the game
so for a bullet game it was very very
impressive and a very correct game and
also
a very aesthetically pleasing one so
congratulations to both of them for
creating such a masterpiece
uh and yeah that's the final position
really really awesome stuff it's not
very often you see a king on e1 and g1
with so many pieces on the board but
there you have it it it did happen and
i'm very happy that it did
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
andrew rowe pietro rossi
uh andrew nelson max gabriel helm and
felix uh
uh close to maya for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one
once again thank you to mr uh samuel
siddiqui for
uh for your wonderful suggestion and of
course whatever
happens in the chess world so thank you
all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day